Okay. Um,
when I train the recruits, you know, the
recruits at the academy
as a modern peace officer,
you're trained in negotiation,
deescalation,
crisis intervention.
Um
we train in first aid
counseling all kinds of things
that other agencies will come to your
call and also do. Okay. So for example
the way it works is there somebody
reports a child being abused in an
abusive household. You're going to go
first.
um child welfare is not going to go and
answer these calls. The peace officer
goes first and so the peace officer has
to have pretty much all the skills that
the child welfare counselor has. They
just don't have the authority for
certain things based on state law, but
they're going to go calm the situation
down. They're going to see to the
child's comfort. Uh they're going to see
to any medical needs, things like that.
Same thing goes for a car accident.
You're going to go first. Yes, fire and
medics are in route. You're probably
going to beat them first cuz you route
driving around and they're in the
station waiting for the call. Anyone
that needs immediate medical attention,
it's you. You're doing the tourniquet.
You're doing the chest seal. You're
doing CPR. You're going to handle all
that stuff. and they're going to come.
There's a death.
A tragedy happened. You got called
there.
You're going to have to do all the
grievance counseling for that family
until the pastor or a chaplain shows up
and takes over. Okay? There's a lot of
overlap.
But whenever that call turns violent,
all these other people will leave and
you have to stay. Okay? So what I tell
the recruits is you better know how to
do CPR. You better know how to grieve as
counsel. You better know how to see to
the needs of a child,
but ultimately you are a violent
specialist.
That's your bread and butter.
You cannot be freaking out
like they will when this turns by.
Same thing goes. We have a lot of
overlap in Buudo with let's say a Zen
monk. They did they just saw Zen. We did
Zen this morning. Okay. They pay
attention to their emotional content and
we're paying attention to our emotional
content.
They have an etiquette. They have a
moral code. We have those things, too.
But they're not going to put it into
violence.
You're going to put it into violence.
We're going to see. Let's, as I said,
this is just moving Zen. You see that?
So, if we weren't freaking out on the
cushion this morning, sometimes we do,
but I don't think anyone did this
morning. That's exactly how much
emotional upheaval we should have felt
in that technique. Okay? Because as we
said yesterday,
with that emotional upheaval comes that
unconscious tension.
With that tension comes the contestation
and there's an overexertion and I can't
rest. Okay?
I have to be able to rest. So, we've
been working out
and the the reason we have to do the
body conditioning is because
I'm never going to get a workout in the
jiu-jitsu because I'm never pushing on
anything and I'm never flexing anything.
You get it? So, that's why on the
exercising I was all faster, faster,
faster, faster because we should be able
to rest in anytime you're doing the
moving zen the martial arts. Okay? So
maybe we're a little tired right now,
but you should be able to rest in what
we're doing. Okay. It's just my own body
weight and I don't contest on any angle.
Okay. All right. So, we're going to get
to our weapons. And we already know from
yesterday, weapons are scary. There's no
doubt about it. Just like I tell the
recruits,
I get that this is scary,
but you're not allowed to be scared
here. Okay? That's going to be our
ideal. So we have to train them to learn
to identify first their emotional
upheaval and then gain control over over
it. Okay. So no doubt weapons are hairy.
Um but try to find your ability to relax
in the weapons and toward that end there
should the brain farting should stop. We
already know the brain farting is
because I'm getting hyped up. That's why
we brain fart. Okay. So, don't brain
fart. Some things I want to point out to
you that you didn't even know you were
doing in the last training.
Yesterday, that technique was pretty
much a kihonaza sort of, but it had
these moments in there where there was
some dynamic timing.
Today,
you could grip whatever arm you could
put your foot wherever you put your
foot. Did you see? And I didn't see
anyone even close to losing the fluidity
of motion like yesterday. Okay. So,
somewhere between yesterday and today
with the purple purposeful guidance of
the training, you're already very
spontaneous with what we're doing. Do do
you see that? Okay. So, same thing here.
This is similar to yesterday but
different.
But you should be able to find yesterday
and today. Okay. So he's going to start
in seon and I'm going to do that atoshi
move with the choke. Okay.
So from here I'm going to come up
and down.
Same rule. Don't hit and give up the
center line.
Make contact.
Rotate the cross.
The weight of your body of your yong
aspect is what pushes that weight onto
that feet. Okay.
I'm here and it's
no not even close to bar dips. Bar dips
are hard. Farmer carries were hard.
Okay, got it. is I should be able to
relax and the more I relax the more y
aspect will drop the heavier the
technique will get and I'm not getting
tired okay try
over push
Look, don't look down.
Just go for it.
Okay, let's do some legato. Thank you.
You're going to walk with pure eyes.
You're already relaxed. Okay.
What stance am I in?
Okay.
How much gravitational marriage am I
using?
Okay, I'm just letting the young aspect
drop. It's enough.
Okay, so to help
I'm I'll do the maneuver
and I'll just You can see that I'm very
ready to keep moving forward.
What do you think will happen?
I got to do come up, shift weight
forward. Okay. So,
I'm going to do my maneuver
and just walk forward. Okay.
Go.
That's nice.
[Music]
You do want this
And then the quick transition.
She wants it push in her in her hand.
She wants to get push on her hand.
See how it goes down,
but I don't want it to go down with my
weight.
My yang energy drops and there's weight
down. Okay. You see it pull her
shoulders. Okay. Try it again.
Don't let it bounce off.
[Music]
Okay. Much better.
Don't let it off.
Don't let it bounce off. You have to
check his height.
Better.
Better
get tight.
That's it.
Down. Down.
So, so you feel it.
You feel that the press down. Do you see
what it does to him? Okay. But I'm just
standing here normal. Okay. It's no It's
no different.
When you punch, I don't have to go here.
The the yawn will drop and he'll feel
like that you felt heavier. You felt
like you wound up more. You see, I'm
just now putting it 3 four feet away
from my body. But inside my body,
everything relaxes. Okay? And then that
force that's dropping down
drops everything down. Okay.
When we give you this task,
if I give you just the tush, that's
where we start seeing
that.
Now I give you the quick transition
and we're not seeing the drop anymore.
Okay. Try it again. You got to get both.
partners.
[Applause]
[Music]
Don't stop. Keep going.
That's what
Hey partner
to be heavy.
[Music]
Good night.
Just walk.
[Music]
Let him hit it. Don't counter it. One
more, please.
Don't resist it though.
You got to come down and attack the
hand.
Stage partner
Chris.
You like
[Music]
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. He is contesting the
touch. It should be the touch but not
manipulate the touch. Okay. I however
would not contest the
just going to make your hands
more vulnerable.
You guys understand what I'm saying?
So
the
the more I push down, let's say there is
weight of his on his feet of X, a value
of X. You got it? When he tries to lift
up, it's now X + Y because he's opposing
the energy. So it will increase as an
opposing energy it'll increase the
pressure the value at contact. You get
that? This is why
as I've said many times in the energy
when you're doing the energetics
when they resist the technique should
get easier because the adhesion value
went up the co value went up. Okay. If
you don't have the energetics, then the
weapon, he'll be able to overpower the
weapon. You see that? So, for example,
in the seated kidosa,
somebody who does not understand how to
use the qua, right, will get overridden.
Do it to your friends back home. Okay?
Do the spinal displacement and you'll
see what will happen. Okay? But somebody
who does understand it, you just made
yourself more projectable because the
energy value that they're working with
is now higher. Inversely,
on the first day, before you were used
to getting projected, we had to reel in
the yin the yin yield, remember? And
what was happening was the energy value
was dropping, which is why you did it.
You made yourself less. Okay? So here
you don't want your hands
because your hands your like
mathematically yes X goes up but this
isn't this isn't math this is
metacarpals to get it on wood do do you
understand so whatever I I hit that with
boom I I hit it now harder because he's
going up
so marshally
I would pin him more. I'd break his
hands more and I guaranteed more of the
ski because he got pinned more. Okay.
What you'll see what he's doing is
there's ever so slightly a yielding to
the pressure.
You see, he is trying to absorb the
energy, not fight the energy. Okay? So
when I'm coming in,
I can I feel the impact and I feel it go
because he's decreasing the value at
contact. Do you understand that? I won't
do it hard, but hold it up and you
you'll see tension go into the shoulders
and it pulls and it hurt it hurts the
hand.
Okay? But it doesn't make my weapon go
up. Make sense? Okay. So, two things.
You
don't let his resistance stop you. You
let it feed you. That was yang. It gets
internalized.
And then, u absorb the energy.
Okay? So, that we're not breaking hands
here. Make sense? Okay. Try it again.
You have to beat in the middle.
Watch how much you're you're doing
externally.
Is that heavy?
Hip heavy.
Down. Down. Down.
down.
[Music]
Not with your face.
All right.
Now, we'll give you the counter
which starts from that initial yield.
Okay. So again, if you look, I came up,
rotated the cross. He's going to rotate
the cross here. Oh my gosh.
Make sense?
If he doesn't lower his height and he
just tries to step out, you got it's
you're going to feel the weight. So he
has to have that yield initially. He
drops, it falls into a hole there. Does
that make sense?
Are you sure? Okay. So, I'm doing my
maneuver.
We'll go to the head on this.
Okay. Try it.
If it gets swung to the left, what was
happening? I'm contesting.
I'm trying to lift on it.
[Applause]
Adjust your mind. Either
way,
[Music]
Let your shoulders drop.
You're neither lifting
nor coming down.
Relax.
All right.
What is my target?
The head. Okay. What is the part on my
bulk I touch the head with?
Okay. Right here. Right.
That's all I gave you. I gave you the
fact that I have to absorb.
Got it.
Where does that foot go?
Where it needs to what? No. Where it
needs to. Where it needs to for what?
Target. Got it. Okay. How much he
penetrates, what his style is, I I have
no idea. I have my mission. I can't pick
a place to go. Okay. So, for example,
let's say I'll figure it out. Okay. See
how he took a little step and then the
full step. It was ever so slow. You
could have heard it cuz his foot made
the sticky sound. Okay. So, I'm watching
the chest pressure.
I'm not going to wait here. Let him way.
I'm never going to get there. That would
be no different from all those
self-defense techniques. You see I keto
where the perfectly straight guy and he
acts like he knows how to box and then
they go like that, right? That that's
not going to happen. The boxer is going
to angle on you. You're too late. You
had to move way before that. Okay? So,
I'm very dynamic. I'm off the chest
pressure. You see how I adjust where I
need to be and I have my hands at
shoulder height. And there's the cutting
portion right on the head.
This is not the right angle for cutting
someone in half. Okay, you can chop him,
but who knows?
Be more dynamic.
Feel what he's doing.
Okay, I might have to pull back. I might
have to go back with that foot. Do
whatever you need to do to hit that
target with that weapon. Okay, go.
pressure on the if it gets hooked on
your side.
I'm trying to lift against it.
Don't look at the target.
Too close. Too close.
I will shuffle back with my left foot
versus right left.
You're going right left.
One more.
Oh yeah. Close your
head.
Okay.
See
that difference?
I want the whole arc.
So when my hands drop below shoulder
height and I make contact, you get a
choppy move.
When you use the entire lever of your
hands so that it hits at shoulder level,
that is a slicing move. Okay? So, I
don't want you to adjust
for the cutting portion with your hands.
I want you to figure out where your feet
can go so that your hands are shoulder
level and you're at cutting portion of
the target. Okay? So, if you were like
that, I want you to go too close. I got
to do something else. Too close because
it's mine could also mean too late.
Okay? Try it again.
[Applause]
Watch the tension in your body.
Watch the motion.
You have to drop some.
Watch that.
Hey,
we go.
What would you say the timing difference
was when he finished the should I touch
the target?
Almost the same. You see that? So,
what's his ability to defend? It
basically went,
you see that? It's not the third
defense. But
that's not going to happen. Okay. Why is
that happening?
Because I am contesting and he's
checking me out is what's happening.
Okay. So, some things that you can tell
you're getting checked out. Aside from
this cadence,
you're going and it gets on your side.
It's over here on your side. It's not
you're So, you get on my side. I'm
trying to pick it up. If I lower myself,
it'll free the sword and I can bring it
around the back of my head. Okay? You
won't have to lower that much, but
that's what's happening. You're not
lowering at all and you're trying to
pick up his weapon and it's making
There's friction over here. You can't
get it down the middle. Okay. Let alone
that cadence. So, monitor yourself for
that was on my left side. It should come
all the way around and freely hit him
right back. He hit himself with that.
Okay. Try it again.
Don't hit each other in the head, but
try to get your cadence.
Watch your shoulder tension. Slow down.
Change.
Don't hit him in the head. All right.
Wait to your left. Turn your body.
Staring at the target is emotional
content
distress response.
Shoulder height with your hands.
So what do you think the elbow the elbow
angle of articulation is at shoulder
height? What do you think?
It's a concentric art. You do one thing,
you do it every place. So, what do you
think?
It's kata.
Do you see that? So, that's not kati.
It's not pokey hole.
Boom. I keep that el that articulation
all the way through back to it. Okay.
Try it again.
Don't look at the target. It's a stress
response.
Get your hands extended, Angela.
All right. Who thinks they had my aiaki,
my footwork? Who thinks they saw what I
was doing?
Come on.
Come on. You don't. You're like, I
don't. I'm not. Do you? Okay. Show us
what it is.
Go in the middle. We don't even need a
partner. We don't need a partner. Slow
down so everybody can see
what you move first.
Okay. Is that when anyone disagree
with that what he did? Come on. It's not
right.
It's close but not right. I don't think
you move it to the side. That's fine. I
did move it to the side. Okay. Try it
again.
Which foot goes first?
I just shuffle back to maintain what?
Chest pressure. The chest pressure. You
see, I don't let him close on the chest
pressure. You understand? So, I don't
want to get an angle and start exposing
my back to someone that's still along
the line of attack. So, I just keep the
same neutral, right? You get that? If I
stay still and he closes on me with the
longer weapon, he'll have advantage. Oh,
I'm keeping the same. No one has
advantage yet. Okay? When you go over
here, you're telling them what you're
going to do. Dude, you're going to the
You're going to the right. Okay? So, you
don't telegraph like that. Make sense?
But what we're not doing
is staying still. Why not stay still?
The chest pressure or he's too close.
It's going to be too fast. He's going to
check you out. Okay. And I'm not going
forward with the front foot. Why? You
just made that worse. Okay. So, as the
person's moving towards you, you keep
the chest pressure neutral. He commits
and you now counter off of that. and you
hitting him when he's hitting you. Okay,
try it again.
Don't move forward. Don't move the right
foot first. Left foot first.
Just because everyone here is now doing
spinal displacement. You see how normal
it is to you? Okay. And so you're
penetrating the target like a real
person would.
When they don't penetrate the target,
you can move the front foot. In fact,
you have to move the front foot, right?
But you know what else you could have
done? Stay perfectly still. Okay. All
right. So, go.
Keep two hands on it.
You got to move out from that edge. If
you trade sides, it's better.
down the middle of your body.
Thank you.
Hand shoulder height
target.
You feel her lifting. Okay. That's why I
got stuck on your side. Stuck on your
left side. You got to drop some,
you got to drop some. You got to yield
to the pressure.
Hey, Parker.
[Music]
Yeah.
Go get this target.
Don't lift it first.
Better. Reach out. Reach out. Longing
positivity.
Reach out.
Don't look at the target. It's a stress.
Out of range, Chris.
Chris,
don't let go of the sword.
Too close.
Don't look at the target.
Travis, go again. Don't look at the
target. Don't hit him in the head. Relax
your shoulders.
Don't look at the target.
Don't look at the target. Stop.
It's the broken record, right? Don't
look at the target.
The stress
will capture your eye. It's a fear
response. You look at whatever's
stressing you out, okay? And you want to
hit that target and so you it drew your
attention, okay? But you can't let that
happen because you're fighting the whole
person and they're maybe they stay
still, maybe I hit them, maybe I didn't
hit them. Okay? But in training, you
want to use me. And me is aimed right
here. Mez is the piercing gaze. It does
a couple things. It will actually relax
you. When you move your eyes all over
the place, it's a stress response. When
you keep your eyes still, it will help
you release that emotional tension.
Though in science today, they call it
the quiet eye. You develop a quiet eye.
So, you're golfing, you're bagging, or
you're shooting the basket, they tell
you look right here on that little ring
of the neck. Let your eye stay there.
Don't move it from there. You let even
though you let go of the ball, keep
looking at that hook. Don't go follow
the ball and see if it was going in.
Okay? So, keep your eye still. It stays
right here the entire time. Okay? Go.
This is your bread and butter.
This is not going to go here.
You are
same thing as UK. Keep your eyes still.
[Music]
She felt the pressure before.
Okay. So, what what you did is uh a kind
of dynamic karm. The mind changed all
the time. You had to change all the
time. You have to know what am I looking
for for mine? Is that chest pressure?
Why am I looking for that? He gets too
close. It's too fast. I can't respond to
that. Okay. Uh it's no different than
anybody who is uh in karate and he's
going to come in and boom and I am
measuring for that perfect front kick.
Do you understand? So the worst thing
you can do is you're going to do your
forms like it's got to be dynamic as
you're going.
Do you understand? And that's a skill
that I have to develop.
We're not just doing a forearm. We're
doing dynamic line.
Now, we're going to go back to form and
learn the technique. Okay? So, I'll
explain what's happening.
You wouldn't come in. He's going to do
his counter. You feel the void. You go
fab.
Right when you felt the void, you knew
you didn't hit the sheet. There's no
point continuing going forward. Do you
understand? What is he doing?
You hit the boy and he's going to flank
you. So, he's at an angle to me. Do you
see that? And what I want to do is go
back and reestablish
the neutrality again. Oh, I'm on the
line and I'm at Joe range, out of bulk
range. You got it? When do I do that?
When I see him
starting to flank me. Don't get flanked.
Stay dynamic. Just like if we're
fighting and he starts to circle, I I
keep myself oriented towards him. I
don't let him get an angle and then
expect that I'm going to do something.
Okay. So, it's very slow. We can do it
slow, but it's going to be dynamic and
fluid. So, I go in, I see him flank, and
I come back out to Joe range, and I'm
now still on his center line. On me,
he's on his center line. Okay.
Just try.
Thank you.
You can still work on not getting
pressure.
It shouldn't come and get stuck on the
side of your body. You're lifting up
against your toe. Lower your center.
Keep your sword there as you do all
that.
No, we're not getting out of the way.
We're just reestablishing neutrality in
terms of initiative.
No, no, no.
We'll do it again.
I'm in and under. Pardon me.
If we go fast and you're going to finish
your cut. Okay. All right. Let me see
you do it.
Got the idea over here.
This is where I'm at. Now, I'm out of
bulk range, but I'm in Joe range. Okay.
Try it again.
Keep your left foot forward. It's all
you have time for.
Left foot forward.
You move to
the corners of the square.
You're picking up. Picking it up. Travis
on the on the left side.
better. That's it.
Drop with your push. No. Come through
the back of your head.
You feel that pressure on the left. It's
because you're trying to pick it up. You
got to yield all the way up in the to.
So, let me see if I can show this.
So when his atoshi energy is coming and
I try to pick it up and he's driving
down, he gets stuck over here. You see?
And you can see my shoulders start to
turn. And it's all cuz I'm trying to
pick this up. If I didn't try to pick it
up and I let his weapon drop down,
my shoulders come right back to me. You
see that? So, I don't ever do this.
Got it? If you're feeling this thing
here, it's cuz you were lifting up
there. It's lifting up against their
tush. And in real life, you're not going
to be able to lift up. He's going to
check your feet and he's going to skewer
you. Okay? You have to be total void in
that part. So, as we're going slow now,
again, I want you to not lift
up on him,
not get
turned
like this. You can go as slow as you
want. This will be smooth.
Okay, got the idea?
Okay, try it. And then he does his move.
You might have to drop.
Don't move your sword when you move back
cuz that's not neutral.
Move to the corners of the square.
Drop drop. He's pushing down.
That's it, Chris.
That's it.
One more
to your
Okay, that is the basic foot maneuver.
Slow it down. And now we're doing
embryionic technical training. Okay, so
I go one, I move here and I'm going to
come up. He's going to finish his cut.
He is now not cutting. You understand?
understand that he is giving me an angle
that I can use to train with. So
yeah, let's say my he could even put his
weapon up. It doesn't matter. But he
does not move his weapon. Okay,
I go one,
two, we make contact. You see how we did
that? Okay, now he stays there. He's not
letting it drop. He is a line for me to
train with.
I am going to rotate the cross. Come
down.
Hit the hand
contact.
I'm in me. Okay. Try.
Reach out. Shoulder height on the hands.
Make contact.
Take his hands up. Virginia.
Get his hands up. Get his hands up.
Shoulder high.
Shoulder high on your hands.
Don't step in.
Relax,
relax,
relax.
Okay. Uh, some of you have done mitosis,
right? Yes. Right. Okay. Um, I call this
an embionic and I told you his weapon is
not a cut at that portion. It's just a
line that I can use to train. Do you
guys understand that? Um,
where I used to train in the Federation,
that was the only timing that they had.
And if you look at it, it's a block. Do
you guys see that? And I will not be
able to block that weapon because he has
the leverage at the distal end of my
weapon. You guys all understand that.
Okay. Moreover, that's a contestation.
That's a young class. So that's not even
the art. Okay.
The So when we do this embryionic, I
want you to lose all of Marshall.
We're not doing that anymore. That's
what I said when I what I meant when I
said we're going to do technical
training right now. Means we're not
doing dynamic high or anything. Okay. Um
so I'll show you what the what the
application timing is for mchiotoshi.
You'll see it doesn't look at all like
the other one. Okay. But conceptually it
is. The only thing that changes is the
timing. Okay. So, we're going in.
This is Makosh. So, at no point did I
block that weapon. I went around the
cross and attack the hands. You see
that?
So, in order to do that, his cut is
coming around and I have to already
be there,
maybe even here.
You see it comes in. Boom. And I'm
smashing it down. I'm smothering.
Killing that strike before it ever gets
out. Okay.
In order to do that, I need a
downwardness
on the smothering. Did you see that? I I
can't do a lateral movement. So, when
we're doing it embriionic
and we're out here,
it's not that I'm fighting his weapon,
but I'm learning how to rotate the cross
against the showman angle of attack.
Okay? And the way that you do that
is I make contact here
and I go around it.
That's the angle that I want. You see
that? What would be different?
Imagine this thing is flying at me and
you're trying to go like that.
Your window
for your angle of incidence is probably
this the diameter of the Joe. Okay. But
if you pay attention,
I'm shielding, right? My whole body's
shielding. I'm not going like this. No
shielding. See that?
And coming up and whipping.
You see that difference? So that's what
I'm doing here. Just embionically,
we're here.
That's the shielding angle. Then the
rotating of the cross and the smothering
part of the technique. Okay. So lose all
just make it a game. The game is
from here rotate around and come
straight down.
That's the game. Okay, let's try it
there.
Slow it way back down.
Not
all the way down.
Don't step in.
Moving it to your right.
moved it to your right.
So, it's cuz you're not dropping under
it.
So, Angelo, you're not a sore cut.
You're going to hold your weapon there.
You're not going to let it fall when she
comes off of it. Okay. She will move it
down
and head. So, shoulder level on your
hands. Shoulder level. And then just
point your wrist to make contact.
Don't move in.
Okay. So, this is a common mistake,
but it's a stress response.
Go back and think about what we're
doing. I came in void. He's trying to
flank and I move over here. And in the
application timing, what range was I in?
Joe range. What range did I move out of?
Bulken range. Do you see that? That
thing is flying at me. And if I mess up,
I don't want it to hit me. Okay. So,
very common thing is you're doing the
embryionic and you move forward in
healing. You see that? Well, application
phase. You did a voc. I hope you got it
cuz if you didn't get it, it's going to
hit you. Okay. Like any fighting thing,
you don't ever get to close the gap for
free.
You have to earn the gap. So, in the
first move, we earned the gap with the
came in after it. Remember Okay.
So, same thing here as we go to this
move. Here's my boom. Now, I can come in
because his weapon is off the block. You
understand? You cannot come in on the
atus. You haven't earned it yet. He's
not checked out at all yet. Okay? So,
it's a stress response.
Just do the movement.
That's it. Okay, try it again.
Keep your feet still.
Don't Step forward.
Get your hand level. Get the hand level.
Get the hand level. So why hand level?
Why hand level? Because that's the my of
his cut when he's trying to cut me. Do
you understand? It's out here. It's not
It's not over here like that. Okay.
Um,
so we're trying when we do an embryionic
train, we're trying to take as much as
we can of the actual application
and we can take the range. We just can't
take the timing. Do you understand? So,
you have to you cut out here and then
for the drill, I'll make contact.
When I go to make contact, I don't want
to make contact like that. That's the
wrong That's the wrong mind. Okay. So,
yes, you did your cut and Bionic, you're
going to make contact. Just angle your
wrist a little more because it's not a
shortcut and it's a line for them to
work with. Okay. Try it again.
No, no, don't let him follow you like
that. It goes to the other side.
don't trap me.
Don't step forward.
Okay. So since I'm not doing the
technique, I'm doing a training. I'm
trying to train myself. Often times in
training, we exaggerate motion so that
we get a better insight into it. Okay.
Um
you saw the dynamic variant and how much
dropping was there of my body? Do you
know what I mean? Did I did you see did
it look it didn't look like that? Do you
guys understand? Okay. But in the
embryionic level, I want you to send all
the yawn aspect down all the way to it's
completely underneath you. Okay? So,
we'll do this drill.
And if you pay attention, I'll I'll show
several variants. Again, you got to
watch what I'm doing.
If I have the power hand out here
away from my center,
It's going to be require much more
internal skill to get that to drop
and to make that heavy. Okay. The more
my power hand, which is the rear hand,
why is it the power hand? Because it's
the most distal from the end, this means
that I increase the acceleration at the
distal end. And mass times acceleration
equals force. Okay? But if I have it out
there,
my weight isn't really physically in and
over it. But if I keep the power hand
here underneath me, when I drop, it
drops too. Okay. So, we'll watch the
first move and pay attention where that
hand goes. That hand goes here. Okay.
First move
here.
I'll put it out.
Oh, sorry.
You can see it's not even low. Got it.
And out. I'll put it low and out. And
it's light at the end. Okay. When we go
to mafia tosh,
the same thing has to happen.
I come over the top. I don't want it out
there.
I want it under me. Look where it's
going. under me. Okay.
So then I end up here,
not out there
here. So when you can now step out of
the technique and he comes to lift
here between my hands,
he'll feel the weight. He's lifting me
out here.
You'll feel the weakness. Same thing. As
heavy as the back end is, that's as max
how heavy the the front end get. Do do
you understand? So if I go out here,
it's very light. Lift the stupid. Okay.
But I'm moving here. I can put more
weight on it. Do you understand? Okay.
So on this drill, you're doing
everything what you're doing, but you're
now cognizant that the power hand always
stays under the spine line under the
ton.
I go over that power hand here. Don't
let it come out this way. Okay. Try it
again.
Your partner will come and lift between
your hands. All right.
Under your power hand. That's it. Under
your spine.
Under your spine.
Good.
You know how to make a weightlifting
exercise. You can tell. Okay.
And for shift and giggles, after they
lift it once, put it out there and have
them lift it again. Okay?
Then put it out. And now lift it.
Then put it out.
Okay.
[Applause]
under your under your center and get
over the top of it. Bring your mouse
over the top of it and your knees. Good.
Put your weight there. Good. Now, push
it forward away from your center and
you'll see. Okay.
Take it underneath. Right underneath
that.
Bend your knees.
Again, I want you to lift between the
hands.
Oh, sorry. Bend your knees. Good.
And again, I don't want you to make a
weightlifting exercise out of it. I just
want you to see, yeah, there's mass
there. It's heavy. And then do the other
one. So, go. Keep going.
Okay. He'll come and feel your weight
between the hands. Okay, that's enough.
Now, push it forward away from your
center line, Chris. And now, lift it and
you'll see the difference.
under your center. Chris, come and get
it. Fouching.
Good. And boy, stay there. And for shits
and giggles, push it forward away from
your center. And she lifts it up.
Okay,
guys. Got it? Good. All right. Uh
each other
and then
okay any questions comments observation
on the very last exercise the power hand
felt like it was right. I don't think my
left hand was right on a couple of them
and so it created a little bit of an
angle that made me tip backwards and
then when I brought it in I wasn't in
the right mind.
Um
third the concept of third gem.
So
um
your where your hands hang naturally
here this is and your joe should be
measured for this. Okay. Meaning you'll
cut it or you'll get it longer. Okay. So
that is third Joe and that is where I
always come in and out of. I never want
to go to half joe. Okay, half joe means
your hand is in the middle of the fight.
In this case, bulk range. Okay, so
you're always at third. So when you're
when you do the the maneuver,
where does your hand go?
Your hand goes at third. Okay, so you
come in, it stays at third Joe. You go
to mafia stays at third Joe stays at
third Joe. Okay, you it does happen a
lot and if you watch old we have a
playlist for Vulcan and staff and you'll
hear me constantly tell people you're
third Joe third Joe and now you can't
get your weight over it. It's too far or
worse you're over here and that really
makes it light. Okay. So, third Joe is
is where you you have to just have it be
intuitive. Your weapon has to be geared
towards it. Um it's no different than um
uh where we put our holsters nowadays.
So, you might have seen some cops and
cops have the 3:00, right? And it's very
department oriented. Put it on 3:00 and
somebody's a long time ago was like
3:00. at 3:00. Um, but the world's way
more violent and how fast you get your
gun out often decides the difference.
And so people uh started looking what
did the old gunfighters do who carried
these guns and they didn't carry them at
3:00. They carry them up here in the
front of their body. So appendix
carrying is now very very popular again.
Uh so off duty you'll you might have
seen my read yesterday. The gun goes
here in the middle cuz my hands are are
right there to go. Okay. Where does my
duty weapon go? My duty weapon goes
right here. So, it's more at 2:30 2:00
max in that area. So, keep an eye out
cuz uh I train all a lot of these cops
around and start looking. You see a cop,
go see where their holster is and you'll
see is that 2:30 or straight 3:00. Okay.
Um, if you see one at 3:30, I'm going to
risk it and go, "Where did they tell you
to put that gun?"
Because they always have to tell someone
in the academy like, "Dude, your gun is
too far back. You want to live or not?"
Okay. But you're starting to see it a
lot more that that gun's moving towards
where the old west had their guns uh
over here 2:30 2:00 kind of stuff. Okay?
And it just has to do where does my body
naturally want to be. So, my body does
does not want to do that. That feels
weird. It's a it's a stress response
where I grab I grab it. You see, I grab
it and now I'm stuck on it and I don't
let it slide back to third or same thing
over here. I'm not aware of this. Feels
very unnatural, very unnatural, right?
And if you pay attention, that's not all
that different from being handcuffed,
which we do to create a positional
disadvantage in you. So, a lot of us
will handcuff ourselves
strange. Okay.
And it just comes over time. Comes over
time. Comes over time. What I would do
here this week is um when we are going
slow, get those reps in. If if I haven't
developed an intuitive sense of where
third is, get those get those reps in to
third Joe. Like you can use your
intellect to try to keep you at third
Joe, back to third Joe, back to third
Joe. And then you'll hear me, you now
know what I mean. like go to third Joe,
you're at half Joe. Okay. Stuff like
that happens a lot.
Um, good good question. And again, if
you something I know, something I taught
but wasn't mentioned because it's just
what happens naturally.
Good question.